[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum it sounds kind of
sexual but it's not
you know some people think the inside
you have had people have told me i had a
shirt on that said inside of you and
people were like that's wrong like uh
the person's like um it's it's a podcast
and talks a lot about mental health and
stuff and they're like oh well there's
always a little chuckle at the end when
you say thanks for letting me be inside
of you to your guest yeah thank you for
allowing me to be inside of your mind
inside of you it's always taken a little
bit sexually though isn't it a little
bit but it's never but it's for fun i'm
not gonna lie it's not that i don't
think about that it's just that i really
try not to think about
that
it's fun to say at the end it is fun
it's fun to say people have a sense of
humor if not don't listen yeah
uh big guest today i love this guy and
if you don't know him you've seen him in
a lot of movies and a lot of tv shows
he is spectacular i had the the um
privilege of working with him in a movie
uh we did a movie called the neighbor
and uh it was a joy to work with him
he's an amazing intense giving loving
person
uh all-in-one
and i loved his stories when you get
someone who's a little older and i don't
mean old like an old man i mean older
just who's lived who has stories his
stories of how he got into acting and
how he made it are just brilliant
i loved it uh before we get into that
letting you know that i'd love you to
join patreon uh ryan what's patreon
patreon is a place uh where you can
support the podcast
it's exactly right you can go to
patreon.com inside of you there's
different tiers i send merch i you know
we talk with with
my patrons who join and if you join i
will send you a message right after
thanking you uh you can get merch boxes
and uh
q and a's live on youtube with me and
there's just a bunch of stuff check out
patreon.com inside of you join today uh
support the podcast it means a ton if
you're digging this podcast it's a small
podcast and you're really loving it
you're like hey i want to give back a
little so be it we really appreciate you
um
also the inside of you online store is
around if you want to buy cool merch
signed memorabilia smallville scripts uh
funko poplex luther's uh lunchboxes
signed by tom welling and myself or just
uh inside you tumblers inside of you
there's a lot of different inside of
things so you can do that and i
appreciate all your love and all your
help thank you for everybody that came
out to watch the band my band is called
sun spin you go to sunspin.com check it
out get a zoom with us oh we played two
shows on
uh
a week ago uh two weeks ago
and uh it was a joy we we played a lot
of new stuff we're working on the album
thanks for all the support so the love
the album's gonna be coming out in a
couple months we're working really hard
on it and we hope you enjoy it and uh
without further ado why don't we just
why don't we get into it ryan are you
doing well i didn't even ask you today i
mean what an [ __ ] how are you i'm
fine
are you i'm doing all right yeah
yeah sometimes i just
sometimes you just
are exist sometimes we just feel like
we're existing yeah we're not doing much
more than existing yeah but you know
what existing is enough isn't it
you're alive it is
it is it's good to be alive it's good to
be alive i mean there's a lot of great
things about being alive one of them is
you're alive as long as you can as long
as you take that second to say yep here
i am i'm alive and that's um that's
that's the key thank you it should feel
good you wake up in the morning and just
go oh no that's not a good way to start
your day but if you wake and go hey i'm
going to make my bed
i'll have some water
i'm going to go outside take a deep
inhale and exhale i'm going to go pet my
dog i'm going to go downstairs i'm going
to make myself a cup of coffee
i'll maybe call my grandma
i'm gonna get up my computer and see if
i got any emails that's a good one to
keep doing call the grandma call the
grandma you gotta keep calling her until
you don't get to call her she loves to
hear from you i love my grandma i just
talked to her yesterday and she's like
i'm bored at this
assisted living place that these people
are old i'm like well
she's 94 in june
talking to me about how old people are
uh she's amazing though i love her and
uh that's all i have to say about that
hey let's just do this without further
ado let's get into the great the amazing
i love you bill let's get into let's get
inside of bill figner
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience so you're seeing all this [ __ ]
you see the goalie mask and the first
thing you said was you played goalie
because i have a jason voorhees mask
from friday the 13th
you were you were you were a goalie
well that's what you know
when did this film come out probably
you know because they don't wear masks
like this anymore but you did in the 70s
and then they started getting into like
baseball catchers and then the neck and
the neck things the neck thing because
of
because of the goalie for the buffalo
sabres clint milarchuk yes yes that got
the skate and the neck that changed the
way they do that but back then this was
it and all you had on the inside of that
were like eighth inch like little like
pads almost the stuff you put on the
bottom of furniture legs and you wore
that that's what we wore that was it did
you ever get hurt like what about slap
shots i never got like if you got hit
hard enough you're like like in a
cheekbone you could split the skin it
didn't happen to me
well you remember the famous goalie for
the boston bruins gary jerry cheevers
yeah um
he got hit so hard on his mask that he
that afterwards there was such a mark on
it he took like a like a sharpie and a
magic marker and he wrote and then he
did the little like stitches on it
and then the next time he got hit in the
mask he did it and by the time the guy
retired his entire mask was still
everything yeah everything just marks
all over his face
uh you know the first thing i was going
to say is i think you look fantastic
thank you
i mean i was like looking you up and all
this stuff and i know you've done so
much freaking work i mean everybody
recognizes you from so many things but i
couldn't believe you're 65 years old 65
and now that that baffles me
i i just always picture you and it's
funny because i
i'm going through like a little midlife
thing i think you know i'm turning 50 in
july
do you remember turning 50 did it bother
you
um
no 27 was the only birthday that
bothered me
what was 26. because 27 was like you
know
i wasn't in my early 20s i wasn't in my
mid-20s i wasn't working i was going
into my later 20s and it was i just
remembered
uh 27 was
you know on november 27th when i was 27
i was like this sucks
um
50 i kind of had a good time 60
i woke up
and i i just i smiled all day long
i just giggled all day long my wife's
like you want to do anything special i'm
like honey you know what i like to do
every day i go to the y michael why do
you think my hair looks like it does the
reason i couldn't comb anything earlier
is because you had to sign up for your
swim time at the y i had an 11 o'clock
swim i had to go right from there boom
hop in the car and come here do you swim
every day at the y monday through friday
how much do you swim how far do you swim
i don't really go by distance i go by
time um i'm going to guess minimum 30
minutes minimum
minimum and if i have time today 30
minutes because i wanted to get here uh
30 to 40.
you know some days are a little quicker
than other days it depends on the night
before but um but minimum 30 five days a
week really yeah and how do you feel
it's why i do it you know just you know
for
i i don't know i like it when it comes
to
fitness in my life it's it's it's not
even like a question ah man am i going
to work out today it's a given i mean
it's just a given it's just what i it's
working out so you're going to swim or
work out every day you know i'm going to
take it there's there's always going to
be one day a week whether it's saturday
or sunday where something's going on and
it's like all right so that's the day
that i'm not doing something or i'm
driving up north or something and i got
to drive 500 miles i'm not going to do
it that way but that's not necessarily
true because a lot of times we leave
here we drive to 500 miles up to truckee
and uh
and you know there's a beautiful outdoor
fitness center in this area where we
live up there where we have this house
and they have two exterior lap pools
outside so you get up there it's 15
degrees out there's a snow storm and
that pool's about 80 degrees oh i'm in
that pool
swimming with the snow coming down
that's that's that's when it gets heaven
so part of the smile on the face is like
i mean you feel good for the most part
you wake up and you feel good you have
like do you feel like you have a lot of
energy throughout the day are you one of
those guys get i get tired all the time
i'm always tired i think i'm eating
wrong i'm probably eating wrong i'm not
exercising enough i'm not doing the
right things
but you think swimming is is something
that i should
i think
i think some sort of fitness for
everybody i mean i think you know
you live up here in the mountains to
walk these hills for 45 minutes oh man
that's like yeah i don't do that i mean
that would be
that would be awesome no seriously do
that yeah yeah i would do that around
here i mean i do that with my dog at
home out in glendale you know i go take
a walk up in the mountains
um
you know to me to have my body in motion
is is
it just that i'm alive you know i want
to stretch i want to you know
i just want to i just want to be
it's just everything about the way i
feel you know the way i look listen you
know you know you look the way you look
you know the age that we get we get
older yeah i don't really care
you don't care i not really do you know
you're not concerned about you because
most actors were concerned about our
looks so you know the right makeup we
got to look good do you want to look
good do you always like or do you kind
of like let it go and like i'm worried
about my performance you guys worry
about that [ __ ] listen as long as my
hair is not too neat i'm i'm happy
as soon as you know my wife's like once
you cut your hair and i'm like why don't
you back off jackson um and i don't care
about i mean
listen i got a i got a good buddy of
mine i you know
i'm this close to telling them hey buddy
just back off on the ice shadow come on
i mean i'm a kim i i'm not i'm not
throwing names out there i'm like come
on alice cooper let's just calm down all
right
how old is he
i didn't say it's kim's saying it's kim
but i'm tired
you think he's going to listen to this
don't tell he just mind he listens to
everything cozy is
a year and three months younger than me
wow
kim coats and you met on black hawk down
and i'm black and you and him and eric
bana became really close friends
forever
just from that movie i talked to cozy
almost the entire ride from the y to
here what do you talk about
you know we catch up he's been out of
town so
so
you know but coach he's also that guy
that you know
and i got a lot of close friends and and
i got one that i wrote uh my phone
called brook with cain divorce uh you
know king's like my little brother right
uh
you know but cozy's that guy we always
we got to have that one guy where
something's troubling me or something i
i i talked to coats about it i talked to
them about shitties put your ease hey
just we're we're those kind of friends
but all the movies you've done
you a handful of people you become close
friends with
you know not more than that it's i mean
you know what it's like we work with a
lot of incredible people over time but
you know when you finish something it's
no guarantee that you're gonna you know
that you stay in touch life goes on you
know or you know there's only so many
hours in a day yeah and the people that
we're close to and you know and and then
i have kids and kids and you know all of
that so you don't get as many that that
are gonna be
you know friends forever you know it's
not like you don't you don't miss them
you know i've just worked with some
great people in austin and who'd you
work with
uh well i worked with ben affleck and i
have before right uh and i worked with
this actress uh would you work with him
on uh armageddon armageddon right
and uh i worked with this actress uh
elise braga
and uh you would know her from uh
elysium and many things she did this
that series for five years about dub
ah they shot at new orleans shame on me
for blanking on it but she's uh
she's really incredible she plays the
lead in this um
you know you work with a lot of great
people and and you hope that you're
gonna you're gonna see him again you
don't know if circumstances are gonna
take you that way right you know
and and i think when you know there is
something about meeting somebody and
working with somebody that's incredible
but there is that thing of like i said
so many hours in the day and then
somebody's going to become
you know how many coaches have i met
i've done 50 films i have one
kim coats
one guy you just hit it one guy it's
just like you know all right you're my
brother you're the same age as me we go
through the same stuff we're pretty so
similar in in life and career so you
talk about prostate [ __ ] with him he's a
guy
everything are you kidding me i'm
talking about with my friends i'm yeah i
was just dealing with some prostitutes
[ __ ] it's fine by the way you know how
was that colonoscopy i got to tell you
something when he got that that you know
hey how you
doing you're bringing that up with no
not a lot well me on the other hand i
probably bring it up with everybody
don't i ryan you do i do i do you know i
look at you and i and after working with
you
and i loved working with you you're very
you're a very giving actor you're very
thoughtful but you're also very present
and that's something i i really i wanted
to step up i wanted to do a great job
because i you know i liked you i was
impressed by you and your work so i was
always i felt like there was some kind
of uh you know uh it was it wasn't a
challenge but i was like you know i got
to make this guy like me he's got to
like me i'm always that guy i want i
want people to like me i don't think you
are that person you don't give a [ __ ]
you do your work if they like you they
like you are you that guy i i think so
it's not like i i don't care but i it's
okay it's okay and i and i want to be
you know liked
you know listen i think you know do the
right thing with people and people will
respect you and like who you are and
want to work with you and
that's way more important i mean i don't
try to be liked i just think
handle yourself in a respectable way
with other people and they will like you
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts
that's different well it's completely
different
just uh being
depleted depleted of energy overworked
overworked not making enough time for
yourself yep have you guys felt burnt
out i i know i have i constantly feel
burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yup
listen to better help
um
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself i don't know how
many times i say this on the podcast be
good to you be good to yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
um i know
that i get so in my head that i
sometimes don't know what to do next i
don't i'm overwhelmed with life i'm
overwhelmed and i just tend to go back
in the bedroom and just fall on my bed
and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ]
if i could say that i don't think better
help it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but um
talking to a therapist talking to
someone someone who's objective someone
who can you know who listen to you who's
a professional
it helps it really truly helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take
take uh all the patrons and all the
people around the world that use better
help yeah take their word for it yeah
um better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy i
can tell you that especially living out
here in california you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
our listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help
better h e l p
dot com slash
inside
i look at your career and i go this guy
must be must have been studying since he
was in grade school he must have been an
actor from
sixth grade on in high school and
college and then i looked it up and i
was like wait a minute you studied
criminal justice and all this [ __ ] and i
was i was blown away you weren't even
going to become an actor it was kind of
by it was a little luck wasn't it i i
almost went to one play in high school
but somebody got a new bong and we're
like hey let's skip the play
let's get to the parking lot right now
and then we'll go right to the hockey
rink
um
yeah i was uh a
criminal justice major i
you know
i've been asked this before and and i
literally think i was a criminal justice
major because i
you know i got into a college because i
had one high school counselor it's like
you know if you tried a little bit
harder you could probably go to college
and i'm like come on
he's like no i'm serious so tried a
little bit harder and then i had to pick
a major
and i'm like
my father suggested you know criminal
justice is
yeah okay
um
no reason
you know kind of like yeah that might be
cool maybe
fbi or something and
by the time i graduated i was just like
there's
absolutely no reason to do this in my
life i just was not in that house you
don't want to be a police officer you
don't want to do anything no i i took
one police exam i took a federal exam in
the federal building in downtown buffalo
and
i think i got about halfway through it
and i thought
this isn't happening but back it up a
couple of years when i was a junior in
school um
i i went to two years to a school on
long island called suny farmingdale
which was a two-year school at the time
an ag in tech school and then after i
left it became a four-year and then i
transferred up to another my dad went to
farmingdale did he really yeah i think
he graduated from farmingdale yeah
pretty sure and my uncle's probably the
same here as me maybe because he's well
he's 70 he's older than you yeah um he
probably graduated 69 seven or maybe
early 70s so anyway i transferred to
suny brockport and i was there about two
weeks
and an admissions counselor called and
said you're short of fine arts course
and i was like what's that and he was
like
you could take you know intro to theater
or intro to music or something like that
in a lecture room and i'm like nah
those classes were all pretty early and
by that point i was like can we get
something that's after like noon
and uh
so there was uh there was an improv
class and i thought yeah improv sure but
they had an improv class back in in
seventies and yeah
no they it's at suny brockport they had
a big theater department
uh
so i thought i had to take one fine arts
course to graduate you had to have one
and i thought
improv sure yeah let's let's go improv
class
took the improv class teacher's name was
sally rubin and she was
she was a hippie no doubt about it right
and
true story it was like
maybe a month into the class and
she asked me one day can you stick
around and want to talk to you after and
i thought yeah i hope i didn't do
anything she likes you baby yeah
so i waited after class and she said
shut the door she came over sat down and
she said listen um
i really think you should do this
and i was like
what
and she goes no i'm i'm serious i've
been doing this for a long time and i i
really
you just you know how to listen
you know how to be in a moment and uh
i just don't think you can
you could teach that and
i just think about it and i'm like i
mean that's like saying to me you know
you want to go to mars and i'm like
it was so foreign to you
so completely foreign and i said
wow and then i asked her
she said you should you know maybe think
about taking more classes because you
know you have two years left your junior
year and senior year so i found out that
you couldn't take the other acting
classes unless you were a theater major
but she went to the department head and
said i got a guy in my class and
i'd like you to meet him and allow him
to take other classes and so i i met him
the department chair for the theater
department he said okay and he let me
take
other theater classes so all my
electives then i just took these theater
classes wow and and it's not like
theater departments are like super
welcoming
no you know
a lot of clicks super clicky they were
not interested in me my hair was you
know way over my shoulders i i left
class i went to the gym i got a
12 pack and it just was not my groove
but i didn't care
because i like the teachers and
i like the experience if she doesn't
call you into her room and say says
something you know she doesn't say
something to you about your improv
skills or your listening or i think you
should take this seriously you don't do
this is that right i don't i i
i mean i look at it as such it's such a
pivotal like turning point like one of
those moments you have in your life we
all have them and you think
am i
wow you know
if if somewhere inside of my head i was
entertaining that you know that like boy
wouldn't that be something special you
know a little confirmation
is can make all the difference in the
world
and and i had that with her
and
i graduated took that police exam
finished about half of it
did a regional audition for the american
academy of dramatic arts i had to drive
to syracuse and do a couple of
monologues for somebody there and
and uh and then like last week of august
i got a call and they were like you know
you're in and
that quickly you switched gears
everything
you started doing plays no i went in and
started studying
uh i didn't even when i got to new york
i i didn't even audition for the first i
would say
maybe
maybe at least three years three years
you just studied you where you started i
didn't i didn't know what to say
no i just wanted to you know find a good
scene study class i went to the american
academy for a year
uh which at the time if you went for one
year
you only went to the second year if you
were invited back i got invited back but
i didn't want to go right i felt like a
lot of a lot of a lot of uh young
students that were there came right out
of high school
you know there was just this feeling
like everybody was you know coming and
you know they were gonna
finish their scene study class and the
limo was gonna pull up and here i am
working a full-time job as a security
guard i got to use my criminal justice
in the new york hilton on 54th and 6th i
literally had a
40 hour a week full-time job i had no
money
40 hours a week and i would start that
job at four o'clock till midnight and i
would go to the american academy from
nine till three and i did that
you know monday through friday and did
you have a passion for it i mean did you
feel something take you over like i i
want to do this i feel this i'm good at
this i i is it something i gravitated i
think i might have i i certainly had
that feeling or i don't think i would
have ever got on the right the bus and
landed at port authority um were you
nervous did did you have anxiety i mean
i felt like everybody knew
like everybody knew
what i didn't know because i didn't do
it in high school and i didn't do plays
in college i took a couple of classes i
felt like you know people
seemed like they had so much going on
and and everybody kept talking about
then i got in a great scene study class
and everybody talked about technique you
know i was like can i buy that at the
drama bookshop i don't know what the
hell
technique is but i got to get me some of
that technique
uh oh man so
i i you know and i
i think this is a little of the the
growing up and buffalo sensibilities of
of not putting the cart before the horse
i didn't want to audition before i felt
like i had a a clue
or a way where a lot of people nowadays
they have no experience and they're
auditioning and they're you know people
want to be famous today they want to be
famous they want to be famous i wanted
to i i wanted to be a good actor i still
do you know i still i
i want to be you know
it's it literally is
a a mindset of its own to have that sort
of you know desire you know
so you put the work in though i think so
when you were there you really just sort
of dove in and did whatever you could
because you people thought you were good
at least this one teacher were your your
colleagues thinking the same thing like
they want to be around you were they
like you're talented you're
did you feel that i had i had a similar
teacher when i got to the american
academy
um i had a teacher there that said you
know
i walked with him after class one day
and he said
you're in it
and i didn't know what he meant
and then i got into a scene study class
when i didn't go back
and it was not the scene study class i
was trying to get in but the guy was
trying to get in had it
had an overfill because he had like a
two-year waiting list and he put me in a
former student named peter thompson he
put me in peter's class
and then eventually i got off the
waiting list and went to like you know
the class and i was there about two
weeks and i'm like i gotta get out of
here people are talking to shrubbery
you know making connections i'm like i
gotta get back to peter but
i remember being in and
in that and you know all of these things
that we're talking about and you know
this just because
just because you know
you may have talent or something like
that
doesn't mean you're going to work or
doesn't mean that it you know your life
is going to turn out the way it does but
i remember being in that scene study
class with peter and maybe this is three
or four years after i got to new york so
maybe i'm mid-20s now right and i
remember looking around at the
and going into that class for the first
time and there were people that i saw
that had small parts and films and i was
like
oh my god i saw that guy in this thing
even though it was like a one scene part
but to me it was like it was everything
i can't believe
oh my god it's the greatest thing ever
but after about a year in peter's class
out of the
20 kids that were in that class
i could tell you
the four or five that were in it
they were all good but i could tell you
the four or five that were in it and i
knew i was
one of the ones that was in it there was
a difference
um
it was just what was the difference i i
don't know i i don't know i i i
if i knew the answer to that
we'd write a book together right right
right it's just something it's a
combination of presents it's something
but even with that you know
is there any guarantee you know
i felt a little always felt behind the
eight ball always felt like i was
catching up and
figuring things out because i didn't do
it when i was younger
everything felt so new
and
make no mistake even though i was
in new york
i wanted i wanted to work in a movie one
day
i really wanted to so you didn't really
want to do plays as much as you wanted
to do yeah
i did i wanted i wanted to learn i was
you know theater was terrifying but
sure you know i wanted to do that i
wanted to
you know i worked on a soap for a couple
of years and yeah what soap was that as
the world turns how did that come about
uh
how old are you take me back there
27 28 29.
uh i gotta
i went to a reading which is what you do
in new york you know it's it's it's the
difference of why i say to when a young
actor oh hey you know i'm thinking about
doing this you know should i go to la go
to new york i tell them i'll go to new
york get a
maybe it's different now but back then
get a sense of get a sense and a way of
how to work
uh which i don't think is really part of
television um you know you walk in you
audition you put something on tape they
hire you for what you put
they want you to come in and do
what you put on tape right you know it's
not an exploration like you know
rehearsing a play or or the rare time
that you rehearse a film um that's only
happened a
couple few times in my entire life where
somebody like rehearses a movie right um
before the day you're actually shooting
it uh but
uh
so i you know did a reading you know
because that's what young actors you
know you re meet a young playwright i'm
going to do a reading of a play yeah we
all do but we're just gathering for
nothing and a casting director was there
from
as the world turns from cbs and he said
you should come in and audition for this
and i'm like ah
i don't know man it was like soap am i
really gonna
is that where i'm going i'm trying so
hard and i'm yet you know it seems like
everybody that i knew
was getting a small part in the film and
that so now i'm like 27 28 i still
didn't get a role in a film got hired a
couple of times
where they they wrote the part out
for real one of them was the film
malcolm x it was a part of a cop like
literally the day before i was going to
shoot it i couldn't believe it i was
like i wrote you out
they called me the day before they go we
got to pay you because you know it's
screen actor skill but it did cut the
part was it heartbreaking did you
put the work in you memorized the lines
i was ready to go
i i i went in and i i auditioned for
something for as the world turns and
it eventually worked out for this
dad role of this young lead woman that
was on the show and i was like i'm a
little young
and we got really good chemistry
together is this weird um
but
they kept calling me back and i and i
went and uh i ended up getting it
god i haven't thought of this in a long
time
the day that they offered me
the roll on as the world turns which was
you know for somebody doing theater or
guest spots and television in new york
it was money like you'd never see and
you're not going to get in theater
and
they offered me a three-year thing on on
ask the world turns and
i got a play on the same day
the fifth lanford wilson's the fifth of
july at port this
no uh the fifth of july fifth of july uh
at the in the portland theater uh the
rep company up in portland maine and i
gotta tell you it was that was a tough
call i really didn't know where to go
with it because i wanted to get things
like working in regional theaters and i
was
and i was like i i i got to take this i
got it
i got to take it
good money
i was on it six months
i went to the the head producer on it
gentleman named
bob calhoun uh
he's since passed away he's a lovely guy
and i went to him and i said uh this has
been really great we all called him cal
i was like cal i can't thank you enough
man it's just been so wonderful but uh
uh
i'm good i i i'm good it's really
and he's like well you've got a contract
i'm glad go waiting he's like i'm glad
you're good what are you saying bill and
i've said well you know just i'm good
it's uh it's it's time for me to go and
uh
boy did he lay into me for the next like
five minutes you got a contract you got
and i was like whoa i'm you know a
little lesson learned and i said i'm
really sorry cal whatever is the proper
correct polite way to go if you can work
it out to write me off
could you please and a year later the
casting director came and said so now
i'm on a year and a half came a year and
a half later goes you still want to go
and i'm like
yes he goes six months from now you're
marrying your cousin you're off the show
it's literally whatever are you serious
six months later
was the wedding and and they wrote me
off do you remember the first time you
saw yourself on as the world turns you
know because you hadn't been you hadn't
done any kind of movies or anything like
that i still don't like watching you
still don't like you've never liked
watching yourself no why
i'm too hyper critical
uh
i i
i it's harder to watch television
because you know a lot of times you know
especially if you're in a series or
something a lot of times you shoot it
and it's on the air like two three four
weeks later i i remember every day i
remember every take
and i you know glancing i'm like i don't
know why they used that take
really you missed the whole moment i
mean you remember everything i remember
everything
what the heck did you do that for and so
then i get critical about about what i
do and a little bit too judgmental uh
it's different with the film a lot of
times the film you know you might catch
a little piece of it and doing some adr
uh but you may not see the whole thing
for a year and it's a nice amount of
distance
um so you kind of can separate yourself
from it i think so but you know some
things i remember um
what i've learned is that
usually by the time if you see a
premiere or something or
you gotta you do a cast and crew thing
by the third time you see it
you know i i may watch myself and go no
it's not bad you know
um
but i still i you know i'm i'm and i
mean this i i am truly not a person that
has that has to sits down and just like
oh man i i'm good damn
i'm [ __ ] good obviously i was blessed
um
just it's not you've never been that
person no i don't think so you uh is
there is there a performance you look
back and you go i'm sure there's a
couple of them that you go
you know i like watching myself i was i
i liked what i did i look back and i go
wow like maybe contact or some movie or
whatever it was is there some project
that you go that was good i remember
liking myself in that contact
context besides that um
i remember the first time that i there's
one movie i watched the first time i
watched it i literally got in an
argument with my agent because i was
just like
why would you think of me for that i was
so i thought i was so horrible
and then by the fourth time because it
went to sundance
and it premiered at sundance and then
there was a cast and crew and there was
a premiere in la so i happened to see it
like three times in a matter of like a
month
and then i i look back and i think it
was probably maybe one of my favorite
things what was it go
really yeah yeah and i now i watch go
and i if i'm flipping around every once
in a while it's on i i can watch going
i'm like yeah yeah you did all right
bill
i'm saying that's good yeah it's a well
you know listen to fast forward a little
bit so i make
you know five years ago we shot it uh
this little film that i made called cole
brook all right wrote it directly
produced it
played the lead in it with kim coats
yeah and um
so here we go you know
three weeks after we wrapped and i'm
back working on mom and i let the editor
put it all together and then i was then
i spent every afternoon with him for the
next three months every afternoon
working on and i found out in the first
couple of days
i found out literally on day two of
editing because we went in there and i
and i said oh i remember this take and i
remember that taken i remember this
taken let's let's put that together and
then i went and got us lunch and i came
back and he showed me what he put
together and i sat there for about five
minutes i'm like played again
then he played it and
this was the conversation that i had
with keir and the editor i said okay
i i'm getting what i'm doing right now
and what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna screw
this movie up because i'm gonna cut
myself out of it because i don't like
watching myself
so this is what we need to do because
right now what i'm watching
is not
a third as good as what your rough cut
was
so
we're going to pick the things that
we're going to work on the next day
and at the end of the day we'll talk
about the scene or two whatever we're
going to go into tomorrow and you're
going to get here a couple hours before
me
and then i'm going to work on with what
you did because i can't cut myself out
of the movie i'm i'm the lead in the
film and i'm going to so you pick the
best things of me that you can come up
well i mean just whatever right whatever
works in your mind whatever it was i
found myself
well don't go to me go go over there go
over this way and and but that doesn't
always work it's like it wasn't working
and i got it like on day two i'm like
don't screw your movie up bill
wow so i had to i had to get over it
watch myself
this is what it is
what about your uh your folks growing up
or when you're doing theater they got to
see you do a lot of theater and or
movies and all this stuff right they've
seen your career
yeah did what they think when you said
you wanted to go into acting i
remember when i told my mother and she
was like
oh
well um
okay let's uh uh let's get to we'll pack
up some sheets and towels and things i
told my father who i didn't grow up with
my father
and i
you know i
it was like i was speaking swahili i i
think he just looked at me like what
gotta remember you know we're talking
back in the 70s yeah you know back in
the 70s i was in high school 70 to 74.
nobody knew an actor
no you know outside of a kid that did
plays in high school but did
nobody knew an actor who knew a real a
real like
professional actor you didn't know
anybody in chickawag in new york
um
so it was
you know so out of the blue to even take
that sort of like leap
um
but uh especially when the first thing
you thought was you're gonna go into
criminal justice you're studying this
stuff and now you're like no i'm gonna
be an actor
yeah it was it was you know i mean
i even remember with friends back then
you know friends that were really close
to me i mean all of them looked at me
like
you're gonna what
um i remember friends visiting me in my
tiny one-bedroom apartment on the lower
east side going like you live in this
thing
because they remember that they came
down with their company car for the
weekend and i was like and i remember
thinking
yeah i live in this thing i love this
little
little box that i live in man i have the
best times of my life sitting up here
figuring out how to make a scene work
um
i have fond memories of those that he's
hard as it was right but
you know uh
yeah it's a heck of a journey i don't i
don't look at you as someone who gets
intimidated but d were was there a time
in your life where
you know working with these big actors
having to step up having to prove
yourself did you get nervous did you get
anxiety did you get intimidated by
anybody
i got to be honest with you and i really
mean this uh
you know you talk about
people have asked me over the time and
i'm a character guy i you know i
play specific things in movies i try to
fully realize that piece of the puzzle
but when you work with with
the movie stars that i've worked with
over time um
they're really good actors
and that's all they want to do
and there's a reason why they're making
movie stars is because they're really
good actors right most of them um
you know so
i i don't i don't i can't honestly
remember that i ever felt like really
overwhelmed in that sort of a thing
back it up for a second not too so i
moved to new york when i'm 21 when i
started the american academy of dramatic
arts and as i said all i really want to
do sure i want to learn theater i want
to work in television and i did that but
i want to i want to work in film
i was 36 when i got my first job on a
film
36
36 years old i'm 15 years wondering is
it ever gonna come my way so by the time
it came around in two years and as the
world turns being in front of that
camera four days out of the week you
know i could have swore the first six
months i was on as the world turned that
the boom was picking up my heartbeat
you know because you're nervous oh it's
just terrified
uh you know trying to be smooth and just
like horrible but after two years of
playing
josh the misunderstood farmhand you know
i mean i really like settled down
um in a good way right and not in a way
that was like i got comfortable
but i got okay about being
letting the camera be in front of me and
now you know
you know and then it wasn't you know
long after that when i
got a few bigger films and all of a
sudden it's a crew of 200 people and and
the cameras right up in front of your
face and and i i to this day say it's
it's like
it's my peaceful zone i don't mind
get 250 people on a set shove that
camera right in my face and
it's just
you love it i it's just it's it's an
easy place because i'm i'm thinking
about you know
my body's in the motion of what i'm what
i'm doing there and what i'm trying to
do with a w
with a role or a character or something
and it's it's all about that and
i don't worry about the rest of it you
just don't worry about the rest of
that's crazy because i talked to a lot
of actors before and you know they're
just like oh yeah you're working with de
niro or something you're like oh [ __ ]
i'm working with de niro and it gets in
your head but you
what was your first big movie where
you're working with a lot of big stars
um
contact contact you're working with jody
foster working with chelty matthew
mcconaughey
yeah who started he was beginning the
rise of his career right yes
and and not at all you weren't nervous
working with jodie foster it just didn't
just occur you're there to do a part
that was what you did
well the interesting thing about contact
was that i
one of my favorite movies first film
mine too
and and not dated
no we're at all the whole thing with the
father at the end still makes me cry
come on it did they download her and
give her the image of something so they
can talk to her and it's in the image of
her dad i mean that's just like
unbelievable incredible first film i did
was the underneath this little indie
film with stephen soderbergh
you like um you hear that yeah it's my
cuckoo clock i should have turned it off
yeah i like it but go ahead soderbergh
uh i worked on this
film called virtuosity uh
where where i learned that uh
they cut 80 percent of what i did in the
film was denzel and
russell crowe and uh they cut 80 of what
i did out of the movie and it was really
great because it was my second film and
i learned right then and there then the
next thing
that i got was heat
and i remember my agent calling and said
this is a big
pacino de niro film it's it's a small
role of uh of a role called van zant
and i read it and i said i'm in he goes
it's not big and i said no but it's five
scenes and you can't cut him out of the
movie
because i learned what virtuosity i was
it was you know what what has to be in
the movie to tell the story i was in cut
it was inconsequential to the story the
part that i played in virtuosity yeah
heat
very consequential and i still to this
day
can read something and go
you don't need that role in the film
um
and it sometimes can make a decision
whether
you know to go with it or not um
but uh
then i did this thing called albino
alligator yeah uh kevin spacey
yeah faye dunaway and matt dylan yeah
gary sinise
so i played a couple of
tougher guys and then
i remember at the time back then and
thinking
i i want to i gotta i want to switch it
up i want i want to do something else
and i didn't work for eight or nine
months and then i was living in new york
and my agent said listen there's this
really cool film with jody foster and
they're called contact but they're not
letting the script out so if you want to
read it there's a part of this
astrophysicist you know
who is blind and if you want to if you
want to read it you have to do it at the
casting director's office on melrose so
people's express was happening at the
time
i got a ticket and i came out
read it in the office put myself you
know went on tape
got on a plane went back to new york i
was back like a day or two
and then
robert zemeckis saw it and then they
flew me back to
meet on it and it was me and a few other
people and uh and
it was like a month later and i ended up
getting it
and that was a that was a huge thing and
huge because it really shifted gears for
me yeah it just changed everybody's
perception of you well i mean that and
and it was and it changed you know quite
honestly changed the way that i worked
on things because a lot of times you
know
you know supporting guys and and films
and and a lot of times those are the
last parts to get cast and you start
working like a week or two
and
and i got cast in contact and they shot
the whole washington dc thing part of it
first
so i didn't start work on a five and a
half month shoot until they were like
you know it was a month away from
shooting when i got hired and then it
was a month and a half of things that i
was not in
so i had two and a half months of
playing a character like that
as soon as i found out i got it i was
like oh i'm so happy that i have this
sort of time to prepare
and i and i literally
lived on the upper west side at the time
and sometimes i would cut across 65th
street between central park west and
columbus and i used to pass by the
jewish guild for the blind all the time
i as soon as i found out i got it i
i walked right down the street walked
right in the front door and there was a
guy named rich paddock and and he was in
charge of volunteer services and and i
said could i please see this gentleman
and i sat down with him i explained the
entire thing to him i said i got this
role in this movie i i just want to be
around i want to get this right
and he just listened to me for five
minutes going
what can i do what can i help with
anything just i just and he was like
cool
and he started to talk to me gave me
some books talked to me about other
things he turned me onto some people to
go to and work with with you know with
dogs this is before i don't even know if
i'm gonna have a dog in the film
you know i i just anything that i could
do
change the way that i approach things
from that day forward because that two
and a half months was as fulfilling to
me as is shooting the film
and after that i'm like i've turned
things down over time where they came in
and they're like uh they start in a week
and i'm like i'll never get it together
i
i i can't put this together that fast i
i just can't i won't
so you were very lucky it was fortunate
that you had the time to really had to
prepare for it
yeah did you ever film yourself being
blind before you actually
played the blind part no
never all i did
was
did zemeckis ever say bill you don't
look blind no try that again i know i
got it i do have a story about that i
want to hear it i would sit in my little
tiny railroad flat on 80th in amsterdam
and once a day for about an hour
i would i got these things like you know
people sleep with you get on an airplane
yeah and i would cover up my just total
blackness i'd sit on the couch
and i just sit for an hour
you hear things
you know people say you know blind
people you know they have their senses
are better well
they're a little more keen they're
heightened they're heightened right um
i found over the next like
you know couple of months of doing that
that uh
uh
i found that i
could make my way around the apartment a
little bit
i found that i was much keener to what i
heard i i i
found that it was
at times really lonely
um and i wondered about that
you know especially the guy that i
played that was based on a real guy that
had his sight and then lost it
and
what's that like and and
not having it and and does that change
things and how people feel about you and
what you i mean
my mind
started to run the gamut and then and
then the guy goes on to be like a
world-renowned astrophysicist and
what kind of commitment is
is that and what kind of confidence then
to go through that and end up at this
place in your life and how special is
that and what does a
woman think of you and and
everything that you can imagine i mean i
went through all of that stuff and then
here i am with my buddy rich paddock
from the jewish guild for the blind and
he hooks me up with people with dogs and
then he's teaching me cane technique
which in my man cave i still have my
original cane that he gave me really
yeah um
and
you know he used to follow me around he
used to walk around the block in
manhattan
and then he would just he would just
follow me and he'd tell me things you
know
and uh so i did that whether i was ever
gonna use it or not and i just had this
massive preparation so we get out there
and then the other thing that i did was
i was hoping
that i would do this without glasses on
like
sunglasses and um
so i started doing this thing where i
practiced
you know focusing on something six feet
away
just focusing on that box right there in
front of me and just focusing on it and
then and then whether whatever came in
front of my eyes it wouldn't make a
difference because i was just focusing
on that and then you i wouldn't blink or
anything and i wanted it a little trick
well i was just i was finding a way of
like not being affected uh of having my
eyes plank or something right right
so we go in this rehearsal process and
like we were saying earlier i was saying
you know there are very few films that
rehearse robert zemeckis rehearsed this
for a whole monday through a friday
before we started shooting read through
the script every day with everybody
and um going through that whole thing
and uh
it was like
the day before we started photography
and
he introduced me to uh
gary and millicent
she was blind he was sighted they were
married
and they were hired as my tech advisors
like the day before that we started and
um you know i'm a young actor really
happy to have this opportunity how old
are you
uh
probably
39 40
and but new in the world of working on
film right and uh
and he introduced him to me as you know
to be
to help me with you know
everything
blind right and i just remember saying
you know
wow thank you and uh looking at gary and
millicent who were lovely
and but all i'm thinking of is
did you really think that was gonna
show up and not
have anything like semi-prepared
and uh and
gary and millicent and they had a dog
with them and and they had a dog for me
there and
you know they had canes to work with me
and everything and i mean after like 15
minutes they were like you got this you
you're way ahead yeah you're like
yeah go do your thing and and they were
and they were lovely and they were
around the entire time and there were
times where i might have a question
did zemeckis ever give you notes or did
you really have not many he just kind of
was like you're doing what you should be
doing
this gets back to like going into my
first like class when i was younger
uh because i never felt my first like
scene study class because i never felt
like i really had the lingo right i
never felt like i could really hang with
anybody and and and talk about you know
well let me tell you about my subtext
i'm like
i never
that scene study class
you did a scene three times
maybe you did it twice or maybe it just
did it once because if you really
knocked the scene out of the park
peter thompson the teacher would just go
that was great man you really realized
it move on
i used to do everything that i could so
we could bring a scene in there and just
do it once because i didn't want to get
up there and like get into detail and
talk about like all the tech lingo
so i would try so hard and i think i
carried that through
in my entire life about working on
something listen if a director has
something awesome to say to me say it i
can't wait man take me someplace i don't
know but i'm never gonna show up on a
set like you know hey what do you think
i should do with this i'm always gonna
have
a road that i'm on you want to put me on
a better road you want to make this road
go further please do um wow but i don't
wait around for it you do the work oh
always always do the work and if they
want to take you a little bit further i
love
that or a lot of times they're just like
yeah do your thing
um
so
did he had a ton to say to me
no and that's that was that was great
you know
i did i think i bugged him one day when
when
he had the dog sitting under the desk
and and the uh
set dressing came out and had a big
fluffy bed for the dog
and
the dog was on the bed and i was like
excuse me um
robert
the dog can't be on the bed right now
and he's got a million things on his
mind he's like why and i said because
the dog's working right now and a
working dog does not sit on a bed the
dog will sit on the bed when he gets
home but it's a working dog he's with me
right now he's working with me and he
doesn't sit on a bed
he just sits next to me
i think it bugged him
he
just looked at me like
all right get rid of this thing ned
um
[Laughter]
oh i love it all right this is called uh
this is awesome
and i loved working with him
he seems like somebody great to work
with have you worked with a lot of
shitty directors or directors that you
just like i i don't want to ever work
with that guy again no nate you have to
name obviously
uh you know
i'd be real hard-pressed to find
somebody to put on that list right off
the top man i really mean that you've
enjoyed most of the people you've worked
with for sure
but i'm a guy that enjoys i even michael
bay i enjoy the job
i love working with michael he's you
know no i know i just say that jokingly
nobody hear things
he's intense he's intense
and you don't mind that
i can see
michael's michael he's
listen we finished armageddon and and
you know like a year later he's like i
got three cameos in pearl harbor come on
fick you got to play one of them
just just play one of them and i and
i've read the three cameos and i'm like
i'll play that one
he said god yeah thanks man thanks
we don't have any money by the way i'm
like you never
jesus
this is uh these are i have these
patrons
um they support the podcast in other
ways they just help out the podcast so
it's called patreon patreon.com inside
of you these are from the top tier
patrons who have some questions it's
rapid fire sure you can answer them as
quickly or slowly as you want
uh zack pappas zach says favorite memory
of prison break which we didn't really
get to talk about
because you played you played a real
[ __ ] on that
you know why you got to go there babe
i'm sorry i mean you were you were tough
misunderstood misunderstood i knew
you're going to say that
favorite memory uh
first two scenes of the first season
that i was in because i came
i was not in season one but then
i remember when i got when i got offered
the job i'm like wait a minute it's i
just they just broke out of prison after
why is it called prison break what are
we gonna do and it was like it's an fbi
agent
first first two scenes when i got to
dallas um
just
i remembered the character and thinking
why is this guy popping pills he's the
fbi agent and he's just got a whole
other rhythm going on and i remember the
beginnings of that
and thinking
this
i like this
i like this a lot you like playing the
character i did i i did yeah and it was
very separate from all the guys that
were the prison break guys from the year
before that and i was i was fine with
that i was just walking on my own road
uh carly shibby says oh hell yes i love
this guy there's a lot of that a lot of
that a lot of people were like oh my god
you got this guy i love this guy
uh question how is it working on
armageddon did you get any real space
flight education
armageddon um
i remember first of all it's a jerry
brockheimer film so you're gonna get the
best of everything and you're you're
gonna get dod approval i mean jerry's
made armageddon pearl harbor black hawk
down
um it's you know you're gonna get the
best that there is i remember being in
cape canaveral where we're shooting the
scenes where we're actually getting in
the shuttle the shuttle the
real shuttle is on the launch pad one of
them and here we are 280 feet up in the
air
at the cantry it's like the plank that
you walk across to step in and they're
shooting this stuff and i'm like this is
just around when cell phones are
starting to break you know
and i'm up there and i remember looking
at our second second and i'm like dude
you got to lend me your cell phone let
me your cell phone right now right now i
get his cell phone and i like i dialed
the number and my mother picked up and
i'm like mom you can't believe where i
am right now it's like it's like i'm on
cnn and it's about to take up i can't
believe it's a beautiful crystal clear
day i'm looking at the waves rolling in
and i'm my hand is on the shuttle i'm on
the shuttle right now that's working on
a jerry film and we had a lot of that
stuff you know working at houston
mission control it was
up at edwards air force base incredibly
impressive
uh carly also says i remember the first
time i watched him on tv a show called
grace under fire played a guy named
sparky such a damn good show
uh leanne any fond memories of working
with rosie that's me on the movie the
neighbor
we had fun it was a little independent
movie it was that was you know listen
that was you know five pounds of baloney
in a two-pound bag yeah and to get that
to do that in the time frame oh yeah we
did it fast and i remember
um aaron the director said
you got to meet with bill before i cast
you he's gotta you know he's gotta
approve you and i was so nervous i was
like oh [ __ ] so we met at this little
coffee place and then afterwards aaron
called me goes okay he approved you like
oh
good guy you know listen
no offense i just wanted i'm like make
sure this guy can do it who who's in
this whole thing
yeah yeah you're the lead guy you want
to know yeah and i ultimately do you
ever see the poster of what they finally
came out with that film yeah yeah uh
like me like leering out the window like
it's like it's a you know like like i
have a knife in my hand i was like talk
about marketing missing the boat
on what the movie was about yeah
yeah well what can you do not the first
uh let's see
lisa hall what was it like working on
the remake of the longest yard with adam
sandler you have any funny adam sandler
stories
adam's got a whole beautiful group that
he works with and
it's all in
his world and his guys and and wonderful
people
i kind of was a little unsure of the
whole journey
um
until the day
that's you know because i just
you know i just trying to do
something with the character and i think
everybody
wanted it to be a little more middle of
the road and and i got that that's you
know that's their choice their movie
and the whole thing
the best day that i had on all of the
longest year and i had a lot of good
days come on i'm playing a football
player i'm a football fan it was just a
lot of fun
i did walk up when when the camera was
rolling and you had these like 300 pound
guys in front of you
you know when when the stunt quarterback
was not in going literally walking down
the line to like romanowski and goldberg
and going hey hey
screen actors kill s-a-g not nfl i'm in
i'm in the game now
um
but my son sam who was like 11 at the
time
came to uh
my wife kimmy brought him to santa fe
where we were shooting the prison stuff
and sam was with me and just kind of you
know looking around at the enormity of
it and
a golf cart pulled up
adam was in the golf cart he was by
himself slammed on the brakes he was
like cause
we were talking about us and my son sam
is going to come visit slammed on the
brakes he was like you sam sam said yeah
he goes come on we got stuff to do
put him on a golf cart took off
i saw sam about 45 minutes later he just
took him everywhere took him on in video
village showed him one and took him on
the scene the sweetest guy in the world
he brought him back and i was like
i love you adam sandler you know who
doesn't
for that moment
what a great moment
come on sue byrne says what is your
proudest moment in your personal life
and your career
well absolutely marrying kimmy um
yeah you've been married what 24 years
i thought you said i thought you were
gonna say you've been married 24 times
no
24 times 24 times may make up your mind
um 24 years right 24 this summer um
yeah uh though i met kimmy uh
years before i married her like 12 years
before
and i knew her just for a few months and
then i didn't i didn't see her for 10
years and
circumstances i i refound her so i was
really grateful about that you know
you can't really go back in life you
know we all know that circumstance
sometimes when you miss something you
try to go back but you can go back if
you never
really had it in the first place and i
had met this girl and she was so
beautiful and then life went on and i
and i was married for seven years and it
didn't work out and then i found a way
to find my way back to her and i'm so
grateful that i that it worked out and
then i refound that woman and uh
so personal life that's right after
along with you know having my two maniac
children yeah and um
and work-wise uh
i just
to have made to to have made cole brook
and
and wore every hat imaginable and like
literally
flew by the seat of my pants i just
i to put that all together i was just uh
you want to do it again i i
i'm in the throes of it right now
and uh
yeah
you listen you know any independent film
you're gonna make you need about eight
miracles i've got like four so far
i need a few more and i i think they're
all coming together and in a perfect
world maybe i shoot it this summer we'll
see this is something i agree with big
stevie w says no questions
just a thanks for being one of my
favorite actors since go
don't think i've ever seen him not give
a great performance
oh that's cool thank you i i don't think
i think that's when you know when you
talk about like committing like you just
do you do the work
it just it speaks volumes i mean you do
the work you get when you're on set
you're ready to go i think a lot of
people sort of kind of you know let me
be directed let me kind of figure it out
while i'm on my feet and i don't you
know they don't know their lines exactly
you seem like someone that knows your
lines inside out when you get on set
yes i mean
yes and then you know and then there's
that other part of me that's like you
know
and that's the experience thing that we
we both deal with is you want to know it
but you don't want to know it's
like you really know it you know you
want you want a little bit of
a little bit of everything um uh
i mean who knows you know we we we try
to just find that sweet spot um that
sweet spot in our life to be alive you
know what i used to call it when i first
moved to new york and started acting i i
remember that i used to call breaking
out which is when
you had the lines
and then you had an idea about something
or a rhythm about something because you
know what it's like if you could tap a
rhythm of a character there's
there's 52 things that you could get
specific about but you don't need to
know all 52 if you find the rhythm right
because then then you just go right and
i think that's ultimately what we all
look for and i i never stop striving for
that
finding a rhythm
and you don't always feel it but you try
to get close to it you call yourself a
leading man but i i i see you character
man i'm sorry character i but i see you
as leading man that's what i was going
to say
i i do i see you as you've done so many
great characters but there's no reason
why you shouldn't be the lead in movies
there's no reason why you shouldn't be
the love interest or the whatever do you
do you
you need to when this is over you need
to start calling the studios
i mean do you what do you what do you
where do you see yourself though
honestly you're 65 years old you'll be
66 this november you feel great you're
swimming you got a great family you want
to direct again
what else is there for you
do you ever think you'll retire do you
think you'll be you know once i hit 70
i'm done acting or are you going to go
right to the end
listen i i
i had one of the best times that i ever
had this past fall i worked with robert
rodriguez for two months in austin on
his new film called hypnotic and
i have to tell you and i'm just i have
to
shout out for this guy he after that two
months he
instantly went in like top three
all-time favorite right with
right with ridley scott
who i always put it at the top of my
list but put robert right in there he
was such a joy
to work with now there's a guy talk
about like
there's a guy that has such a style
and he's such an earthy wonderful person
i never experienced anything like going
on set with him because when robert
would tell me something
i really wanted to hear exactly what
because i really wanted to fall into the
world of how he makes movies
i i just literally not that i didn't
prepare things but
everything he told me i'm like i want to
do that exactly what you just said i
want to try to get that um so i came
back from that let's say i finished on a
friday flew back on a saturday
you know
people would ask me friends you're going
to chill out i'm like yeah i'm going to
chill out tomorrow and then i want to
start something on monday i mean that's
the way i am about everything you know i
a few things have come my way they
weren't the right things but it was like
four months ago four months from me
i i'm going a little nuts i i you know i
want to be engaged all the time yeah
there's going to be a time when i'm like
you know i want to go fishing and that
day's not yet
um i want to work all the time i want to
do things do i ever think that i do i
think i'll ever stop you know having the
desire to work i highly doubt it
i highly doubt you love it that much i
just it's just
it's what i do and you know and and as
we get older you you you
you know hopefully you're you're better
and i just
have a real desire to uh
be the best that i can be
i love it do you ever have you thought
of uh ever calling
the hippie uh teacher is she still alive
so
i don't know if she is but so i
graduated
suny brockport in 78 and i would say
probably
like late 80s because i had a
well i always had a car even when i had
no money in new york i was at a junker i
had
i had to have a car to go to the
catskills on the weekend to go hiking or
jump in some stream always
but i remember driving home
probably late 20s early 30s maybe
and i stopped at a a
new york state rest area you know along
the new york state throughway
and i walked in
and there she was what
sally rubin there she was and i walked
up to her
and i sat with her for a few minutes and
we had a cup of coffee and i told her
where i was and what i was doing and i
it started to work and everything and it
was really lovely and i'm sure we traded
numbers and
life goes on and but i did see her one
more time
after we left after we left school
that's that's i don't know why that
makes me a little emotional that's kind
of cool that's just you know
so cool it's a cool thing that just on
an unexpected moment unexpected moment
don't yeah long time ago i love it
uh this has been awesome
i i love talking to you i i learned a
lot about you that i didn't know about
that we didn't get to talk about on the
set
which we didn't talk about
i mean we didn't talk about stuff that i
mean i went to your house i hung out
with your family yeah
and now you have a new house up and
where
up in truckee
you got to invite me sometimes you're
going to have a big party have a big
batch it's so beautiful up there
yeah it's like it's like my college age
boy was like you know this place is
awesome man i can't wait to go with the
guys and i'm like no no no no no no no
no no no you're not going with the gun
oh god bill thanks for being on i really
appreciate you what a joy man pleasure
to talk today great to see you great
seeing you
i just love the stories i love the
stories about the acting class i love
the stories about how he got into acting
how uh you know working with great
people um his nerves and how he you know
the confidence that he gets and how he
does it just his process and yeah um
yeah like when you talk to the seasoned
vets it really gives you some
perspective on things yeah because
everybody's path was different
everybody's path is different
and uh he definitely gives you some
perspective thanks bill i really
appreciate our conversation i hope to
see you soon
um again join patreon uh support the
podcast patreon.com inside of you go to
the inside you online store if you want
any merch i'm on cameo
blah blah blah go to sunspin.com if you
want to get a zoom from the band or you
want to support the band or get banned
merch i think i've said it all i'll be
in metropolis illinois june 12th weekend
with tom willing um doing smallville
nights and signing autographs i hope you
guys join
um there's a lot of um
craziness going on in the world like
like always there's always something
that just kind of is devastating you
know and we didn't talk about it but all
the lives that were lost
just uh
you know it kills you it kills you and
there's you feel helpless and you're
like you know what do we do well there's
things you can do there's places you
could donate there's petitions you can
sign there's things that
you know we have to keep doing something
because
doing nothing isn't working
um we've got to change some minds of
some people in the upper
you know
senate if you will we've got to change
some minds and
the direction of the country and where
we're going it just amazes me how i
don't want to get political but i'm just
saying how australia banned the use of
certain guns and they haven't had any
massive shootings
since
every time this happens like this this
is they said they sent the facts about
like what the other countries did yeah i
just i just you know want this to stop
shouldn't be a priority it's it's
children we're talking about here it's
human life and
i don't know it's just it's devastating
so look be good to yourself be good to
others
and uh thanks for listening to the
podcast today i appreciate you
join us next week we'll have another
great guest and spread the word spread
the word on twitter
instagram all that stuff did we do the
handles
yeah they're at inside your pod on
twitter and saudi podcasts on instagram
facebook that's correct so write a
review too it really helps when you guys
write a review about what you thought
about the podcast it enormously helps it
gets us up in the rankings it gets
people kind of uh more awareness to us
so that really helps and that's about
all i have to say about that so let's
get into the uh top tier patrons let's
do it
here we go
nancy d leah yes sarah f
yes
sarah that's correct little
lisa you kiko jill e brian h nico p
roberts
uh b jason
w kristen
k raj c joshua d cj p jennifer n stacy
jamal
f janelle
b
kimberly e mike
e eldon
santiago m chad d
w
w's correct leanne
maya p maddie s belinda
n
chris
h dave h
sheila g brad d ray h
tabitha t tom and you got through the
first page these guys have been here
though
these guys have been here so it's easier
to do that oh yeah liliana
a talia
t m
betsy
d chad
d l
rochelle
marion
meg
k correct trav l dan
c big stevie w it's dan n
dan dannon like the yo from dannon yeah
big stevie w angel m rhiannon c cory k
super sam
dev nixon michelle a jeremy c andy t
cody r gavinator david c john b brandy d
yvore camille s the c joey
fatone m joey m william david h omar i
design otg eugene and
uh oh um eugene me leah leah correct
chris p nikki g cory nicole patricia
heather l jake b james b bobbitt joshua
b tony g megan t mel s orlando c john b
caroline r rob e paul c christine s
sarah s
eric h spring hi spring jennifer r shane
r m r
mark m
jeremy v
andrew m rupert
no robert
g
and satoichi 77
77. we'll find out in a few weeks if you
guys yeah i'm trying i'm trying
uh from the hollywood hills in
california i'm michael rosenbaum the
bride tales over here that's right
and a little wave of the camera hey guys
thank you for allowing me the inside of
each and every one of you um it's a joy
it's a joy um and uh be good to yourself
i always say that but uh if you if
you're not good to yourself who you're
not gonna be good to anybody else are
you it's true yeah let's do it let's
just uh it's okay have a good day we'll
talk to you
[Music]